if you followed some of the mathematics
and some of the thermodynamic principles
in the last several videos what occurs
in this video might just blow your mind
so not to set expectations too high
let's just start off with it
so let's say i have a container and in
that container i have gas particles
gas particles inside of that container
they're bouncing around like gas
particles tend to do creating some
pressure on the container of certain
volume and let's say i have n particles
i have n particles
now each of these particles could be in
x different states so let me write that
down
each each particle
each particle
can
be
in x different states
different
states what do i mean by a state well
let's say i take particle a let me make
particle a a different color particle a
could be down here in this corner and it
could be have some velocity like that it
could also be in that corner and have a
velocity like that those would be two
different states it could be up here and
have a velocity like that it could be
there and have a velocity like that if
you were to add up all the different
states and there would be a gazillion of
them you would get x particle that blue
particle could have x different states
you don't know we don't we're just we're
just saying look i have this container
it's got n particles and we just know
that each of them could be in x
different states now if each of them can
be in x different states how many total
configurations are there for the system
as a whole
well particle a could be in x different
states
and then particle b could be in x
different places so times x if we just
had two particles then you would
multiply all the different places where
x could be times all the different
places where this the red particle could
be and then you'd get all the different
configurations for the system but we
don't have just two particles we have n
particles
so you'd be multiplying
for every particle you'd multiply it
times the number of states it could have
and you do that a total of n times
n times and this is really just
combinatorics here
you do it n times this system would have
n configurations for example if i had
two particles each particle had three
different potential states how many
different configurations could there be
well each could for every three that one
particle could have the other one could
have three different states so you'd
have nine different states you would
multiply them if you had another
particle with three different states
you'd multiply that by three so you have
27 different states
here we have n particles each of them
can be in x different states so the
total number of configurations we have
for our system x times itself n times is
just x to the n
so we have x to the n states
in our system
now let's say that we like thinking
about how many states a system can have
certain states have less for example if
i had fewer particles i would have fewer
potential states or maybe if i had a
smaller container i would also have
fewer potential states there would be
fewer potential places for our little
particles to exist
so i want to create some type of state
variable that tells me how many states
can my system be in so this is kind of a
macro state variable
it tells me how many states can my
system be in and let's call it s for
states
s4 states for the first time in
thermodynamics we're actually using
a a letter that in some way is related
to what we're actually trying to measure
s for states
and since the states they can grow
really large let's say i like to take
the logarithm of the number of states
and this is how i'm defining my state
variable i get to define it so i get to
put a logarithm out front so let me put
a logarithm
so in this case it'd be the logarithm of
my number of states so it'd be x
to the n where this is
number
of potential states
potential states
and you know we need some kind of
scaling factor maybe i'll
change the units eventually so let me
put a little constant out front
a little constant every every good
formula needs a constant to get our
units right i'll make that a lowercase k
so that's my definition i call this my
states
state variable if you give me a system i
should in theory be able to tell you how
many states the system can take on
fair enough so let me
close that box right there now
let's say that i were to take my my box
that i had
let me
copy and paste it
i take that box
and it just so happens that there was an
adjacent box next to it they share this
wall
they're identical in size although what
i just drew isn't identical in size but
they're close enough they're identical
in size and what i do is i blow away
this wall i just evaporated all of a
sudden it just disappears
so this wall just
disappears
now what's going to happen
well as soon as i blow away this wall
this is very much not an isostatic
process right all hell's going to break
loose i'm going to blow away this wall
and you know the particles the particles
that we're about to bounce off of the
wall are just going to keep going
right they're going to keep going until
they can maybe bounce off of that wall
so very right when i blow away this wall
there's no pressure here because these
guys have nothing to bounce off to while
these guys don't know anything they
don't know anything until they come over
here and say oh no wall so the pressure
is in flux even the volume is in flux as
these guys make their way across the
entire expanse of the new of the new
of the new volume so everything is in
flux right and so what's our new volume
if we call this volume
if we call this volume what's this this
is now two times the volume
we now have two times the volume let's
think about a couple of some of the
other state variables we know we know
that we know that the pressure is going
to go down we can even relate it because
we know that our volume is twice it is
two times the volume what about the
temperature
what about the temperature well the
temperature change temperature is
average kinetic energy right or it's a
measure of average kinetic energy so all
of these molecules here they have each
of them have kinetic energy they could
be different amounts of kinetic energy
but temperature is a measure of average
kinetic energy
now if i blow away this wall does that
change the kinetic energy of these
molecules no it doesn't change it at all
so the temperature is constant
so this is if this is t1
then the temperature of this system here
is t1
and you might say hey sally that doesn't
make sense in the past when the piston
when my when my cylinder expanded my
temperature went down and the reason why
temperature went down in that case is
because your molecules were doing work
they expanded the the container itself
they pushed up the cylinders so they
expended some of their kinetic energy to
to do the work in this case i just blew
away that wall these guys did no work
whatsoever so they didn't have to expend
any of their kinetic energy to to do any
work so their temperature did not change
so that's interesting fair enough
well in this new world
in this new world what happens
eventually i get to a situation where my
molecules fill the container
right we know that from common sense and
if you think about it on a micro level
why does that happen it's not a mystery
you know on this direction things were
bouncing and they keep bouncing but when
they go here there used to be a wall and
they'll just keep going and then they'll
start bouncing here so when you have
gazillions of particles doing a
gazillion of these bounces eventually
they're they're just as likely to be
here as they are over there
now let's do our computation again
in our old situation
when we just looked at this each
particle could be in one of x places or
one of x states
now
it could be what what's
it could be in twice as many states
right now each
particle each particle
could be in 2x different states why do i
say 2x because i have twice the area to
be in now the states aren't just you
know position in space but
everything else i have just i have
so you know before here i could have had
maybe i had a positions in space
times
b
positions or b
uh momentums you know where those are
all the different momentums and that was
equal to x
now i have
two a positions in volume that i can be
and i have twice the volume to deal with
so i have two a
positions in volume i can be at but my
my my momentum states are going to still
be i just have b momentum states so this
is equal to 2x i now can be in two x
different states just because i have two
times the volume to to travel around in
right so how many states are there for
the system well each particle can be in
2x states so it's 2x times 2x times 2x
and i'm going to do that
n times
n times so my new s so this is
you know let's call this s initial
so my s final
my new way of measuring my state is
going to be equal to that
little constant that i threw in there
times the natural log
times the natural log of the new number
of states so what is it it's 2x to the n
power
so it's 2 x
to the n power
so my question to you is
what is my change what is my change in s
when i blew away the wall when i you
know there was this room here the entire
time
although these particles really didn't
care
because this wall was there so what is
the change in s when i blew away this
wall and just to be clear the
temperature didn't change because no
kinetic energy was expended and this was
all in isolation i should have said it's
adiabatic there's no transfer of heat so
that's also why the temperature didn't
change so what is our change in s
our change in s
is equal to our s final minus our s
initial which is equal to what's our s
final it's this expression right right
here
it is k
times the natural log and we can write
this as 2 to the n x to the n that's
just exponent rules and from that we're
going to subtract out
our initial
our initial s value which was this k
natural log of x to the n
k
natural log of x to the n now we can use
our logarithm properties to say well you
know you take the logarithm of a minus
the logarithm of b you can just divide
them so this is equal to k i could
factor that out times the logarithm
of 2 to the n
let me it's uppercase n
so let me do that this is uppercase n i
don't want to get confused with moles
uppercase n is the number of particles
we actually have so it's 2 to the
uppercase n times x to the uppercase n
divided by
x to the uppercase n
so we can just these two cancel out so
our change in s is equal to k
times the natural log of 2 to the n or
if we want to use our logarithm
properties we could throw that n out
front and we could say our change in s
our change in s whatever this state
variable i've defined and this is a
different definition than i did in the
last video
is equal to
k
or let me say n
big n the number of molecules we have
times my little constant
times the natural log of two so by
blowing away that wall and giving and
giving my
and giving my molecules twice as much
volume to travel around in my change in
this little state function i defined is
n k the natural log of two and what am i
what what really happened i mean it
clearly went up
right i clearly have a positive value
here this is natural log of 2 is a
positive value
n is a positive value it's going to be a
very large number the number of
molecules we had
and i'm assuming my constant i threw on
there is a is a positive value but what
am i really describing i'm saying that
look by blowing away that wall
my system can take on more states
there's more different things it can do
and we'll i'll throw a little word out
here it's entropy has gone up and
entropy well well actually let's just
define s to be the word entropy we'll
talk more about the word in the future
its entropy has gone up which means the
number of states we have has gone up i
shouldn't use the word entropy without
just saying entropy i'm defining is
equal to s but let's just keep it with s
s for states the number of states we're
dealing with has gone up and it's gone
up by this factor actually it's gone up
by a factor of two to the n and that's
why it becomes n natural log of two fair
enough now you're saying okay this is
this is nice sal you have this this this
this
statistical way or i guess you could
this combinatoric way of measuring how
many states this system can take on and
you looked at the actual molecules you
weren't looking at the kind of the macro
states and you were able to do that you
came up with this macro state that says
that's essentially saying how many
states can i have but how does that
relate to that s that you defined in the
previous video
remember in the previous video i was
looking for a state function that dealt
with heat
and i defined s or change in s
i defined a change in s
to be equal to the heat added to the
system divided by the temperature
that the system that the heat was added
at
so let's see if we can if we can come up
if we can see whether these two things
make the same
you know if these things are somehow
related so let's go back to our system
and go to a pv diagram and see if we can
do anything useful with that
so pv diagram
all right
okay
so this is pressure this is volume
now when we started off before we blew
away the wall we had some pressure and
some volume so this is
v1 and then we blew the way the wall and
we got to
actually let me do a little bit
differently
oh no i wanted to
i don't want that to be just right there
let me make it
right
there so that is
that is our v1 this is our original
state that we're in
so state initial or however we wanted
that's our initial pressure then we blew
away the wall and our volume doubled
right so this is we call this 2
v
1 our volume doubled our pressure would
have gone down and we're here
right that's our state two
that's this scenario right here after we
blew away the wall now what we did was
not a quasi-static process i can't draw
the path here because right when i blew
away the wall all hell broke loose and
things like pressure and volume weren't
well defined eventually it got back to
an equilibrium
where this filled a container and
nothing else was in flux and we could go
back to here and we could say okay now
the pressure and the volume is this but
we don't know what happened in between
that so if we wanted to figure out our q
over t
or the heat into the system we learned
in the last video the heat added to the
system is equal to the work done by the
system we'd be at a loss because the
work done by the system is a the area
under some curve but there's no curve to
speak of here because our system wasn't
defined while it was in while all the
hell had broken loose so what can we do
well remember this is a state function
this is a state function so and this is
a state function and i showed that in
the last video so it shouldn't be
dependent on how we got from there to
there right so this change in entropy or
actually let me be careful with my words
this change in s
the change in s so this you know s2
minus s1 should be independent of the
process that that got me from s1 to s2
so this
is independent of whatever crazy path i
mean i could have taken some crazy
quasi-static path like that right
so i can any path that goes from this s1
to this s2 will have the same heat going
into the system or should have the same
let me take that any any any system that
goes from s1 to s2 regardless of its
path will have the same change in
entropy because they're or they're same
change in s because their s was
something here and it's something
different over here and you just take
the difference between the two
so what's a system that we know that can
do that well we can go on we can say
that well let's say that we did a
isothermal and we know that these are
the same isotherm right
we know that the temperature didn't
change
i told you that because no kinetic
energy was expended and none of the
particles did any work so we can say we
can think of a theoretical process in
which you know instead of doing
something like that instead of doing
something like that we could have had a
situation where we started off with our
original container
with our
molecules in it we could have put a
reservoir here that's equivalent to the
temperature that we're at and then this
could have been a piston
that was maybe we were pushing on it
with you know some rocks that are
pushing in the leftwards direction and
we slowly slowly removed the rocks
so that these gases could push the
piston and do some work and fill this
entire volume or twice the volume and
then the temperature would have been
kept constant by this heat reservoir so
this type of a process is kind of a
sideways version of what i've done in
the carnot diagrams that would be
described like this
you'd go from this state to that state
and it would be a quasi-static process
along an isotherm
so it would look like that so you could
have a curve there
now for that process
what is
the area under the curve
what is the area under the curve there
well the area under the curve is just
the integral
and we've done this multiple times from
our initial volume to our second volume
which is twice it
of p times our change in volume right p
is our height times our little changes
in volume gives us each rectangle and
then the integral is just a sum along
all of these so we get our that's
essentially the work that this this
system does
right and the work that this system does
since we are on an isotherm it is equal
to the heat added to the system because
our internal energy didn't change
so what is this we've done this multiple
times but i'll redo it so this is equal
to the integral of v1
to 2v1 pv equals nrt
right nrt so p is equal to nrt over v
n r t
over v dv
and the t is t1 now all of this is
happening along an isotherm so all of
these terms are constant
so this is equal to the integral from v1
to 2v1 of
nrt1 times 1 over vdv i've done this
integral multiple times
and so this is equal to
i'll skip a couple of steps here because
i've done it in several videos already
the natural log
of 2v1 over
v1 right the anti-derivative of this is
the natural log take the natural log of
that minus the lateral log of that which
is equal to the natural log of 2v1 over
v1
which is just the same thing as
nrt1 times the natural log of 2
interesting
now let's add one little
one little
interesting thing to this to this
equation so
this is nrt but if i wanted to write in
terms of the number of molecules n is
the number of moles so i could rewrite
this as
i could rewrite n as the number of
molecules we have divided by
6 times 10 to the 23rd power
right that's what n can be written as so
if we do it that way then what is our
what is remember all of this we were
trying to find the amount of
work done by our system
right but if we do it this way this
equation will turn into
so let's see the work done by our system
this is our quasi-static process it's
going from the same state
that's going from this state to that
state but is doing it in a quasi-static
way so that we can get an area under the
curve
so the work done by this system is equal
to i'll just write it n times r over 6
times 10 to the 23rd
times t 1
natural log of 2
fair enough let's make this into some
new constant
for convenience let me call it a
lowercase k
so the work we did is equal to the
number of particles we had times some
new constant we'll call that boltzmann's
constant so it's really just 8 divided
by that
times
t1 times the natural log of two
fair enough
now that's only in this situation the
other situation did no work
right so i can't talk about this this
system doing any work but this system
did do some work and since it did it
along an isotherm
delta the change in internal energy is
equal to zero
so the change in internal energy
which is equal to the heat applied to
the system
minus the work done by the system this
is going to be equal to zero since our
temperature didn't change
so the work is going to be equal to the
heat added to the system
so the heat added to the system
by our
by our little our little reservoir there
is going to be so the heat is going to
be the number of particles we had times
boltzmann's constant times our
temperature that we're on the isotherm
times the natural log of 2. and all this
is byproduct of the fact that we doubled
our volume
now in the last video i defined change
in s is equal to q divided by the heat
added divided by the temperature at
which i'm adding it
so for this system this quasi-static
system what was the change in s how much
did our s term our s state change by
so change in s is equal to heat added
divided by our temperature our
temperature is t1 so that's equal to
this thing n
k
t 1 times the natural log of 2
all of that over t1
so our delta these cancel out and our
change in our s quantity
is equal to
is equal to n
k
times the natural log of two
now you should be starting to experience
an aha moment when we defined in the
previous video we were just playing with
thermodynamics and we said gee we'd
really like to have a state variable
that deals with heat and we just made up
this thing right here
that said change in that state variable
is equal to the heat applied to the
system divided by the temperature at
which the heat was applied and when we
when we used that definition
the change in our s value from this
position to this position for a
quasi-static process
ended up
being this n k natural log of 2. now
this is a state function state variable
it's not dependent on the path
so any process that gets from
that gets from here that gets from this
point
to that point has to have the same
change in s
so the delta s for any process
is going to be equal to that same value
which was n
in this case k
times the natural log of 2. any system
by our definition right it's a state
variable i don't care whether they're
you know disappeared or the path with
some crazy path it's a state it's only a
function of that and of that our change
in s
so given that even this system we said
that this system that we started the
video out with it started off at this
same v1 and it got to the same v2 so by
the definition of the previous video by
this definition
its change in s
its change in s is going to be the
number of molecules times some constant
times the natural log of 2.
now that's the same exact result we got
when we thought about it from a
statistical point of view when we were
saying how many more different states
can this system take on
and what what's what's what's
mind-blowing here is that what we
started off with was just kind of a nice
you know
macro state in our little carno engine
world that we didn't really know what it
meant but we got the same exact result
than when we try to do it from a
measuring the number of states a system
could take on
so all of this has been a long two video
winded version of an introduction to
entropy
entropy entropy and in thermodynamics
a change in entropy entropy is s
where i think of it s for states and the
thermodynamic or carnot cycle or carnot
engine world is defined as
the change in entropy is defined as the
heat added to system divided by the
temperature at which it was added
now in our in our statistical mechanics
world we can define
entropy
we define entropy
as some constant
and let's it's especially convenient if
this is boltzmann's constant some
constant times
times the natural log
of the number of states we have
sometimes it's written as omega
sometimes other things this times the
number of states we have and what we
just showed in this video is these are
equivalent definitions or at least for
that one case i just showed you
this is equivalent definitions when we
used the number of states for this how
much did it increase we got this result
we got this result and then when we use
the thermodynamic definition of it we
got that same result and if we assume
that this constant is the same as that
constant if they're both boltzmann
boltman's constant both 1.3 times 10 to
the minus 23 then our definitions are
equivalent and so the intuition of
entropy we were in the last one we were
kind of struggling with it we just
defined it this way but we're like what
does that really mean what change in
entropy means is how many more states
can the system take on you know
sometimes when you learn it in in your
in your high school chemistry class
they'll call it disorder
and it is disorder but i don't wanna you
know i don't want you to think that it's
somehow
you know a messy room has higher entropy
than a clean room which some people
sometimes use as an example that's not
the case what you should say is is that
a stadium full of people has more states
than a stadium without people in it that
has more entropy or actually i should
even be careful there let me say a
stadium with let's say a stadium at a
high temperature has more entropy than
my than the inside of my refrigerator
that the particles in that stadium have
more potential states than the particles
in my refrigerator now i'm going to
leave you there and we're going to we're
going to take our definitions here which
i think are pretty profound this and
this is the same definition and we're
going to apply that to talk about the
the second law of thermodynamics and
actually just a little side i write
omega here but in our example
this was
this was 2 to the n
and so that's why it simplified this was
the the magnet or no sorry this was x
the first time and then the second time
it was this was x to the n the first
time then the second time when we double
the size of our room or our volume it
was x to the n times 2 to the n i just
want to make sure you realize how what
this omega relates to relate relative to
what i just went through anyway see in
the next video